so we have first that hope you basic so
his energies so throughout the movement
none of that you keep doing so the
entire time that I'm moving it's still
in the ground even though it's turning
everyone of this turn is goes into the
ground let's call that let's call this
level zero this is up racing okay and
let's call this level one where at every
vector point in the movement I keep
vectoring it down into the ground so he
pushes through me to the earth okay so
when you feel for example now
so number one is racing what what is it
was trying to define us
I'm pushing on the first to push I'm
trying to keep his energy external level
one is I do there is some rebound energy
to the earth but he's pushing me into
the earth so level zero I'm pushing
against the earth pushing here to keep
his energy from coming into the one that
is energy I want his energy okay so I'm
gonna do level zero
keeping him out there's little
rebounding as you can see but watch as
the energy comes in his energy strength
this energy comes in and pushes me so
what can I see from that's different I
think you can't see that
[Music]
there's the rebound
so levels 0 is be pushing on the earth
trying to come out the one allows him to
come through me and push me down the
rebound so it's not so much a clash you
get it because energy came here hit the
ground went back there so I'm not one
with that yeah but level 2 is energy
comes in history it's going to rebound
and I don't write it back ok so level 1
you can do climb out this place
level 2 is better if he's like
[Music]
so you gotta kind of make him to mix
you're a social aggression you get it so
[Music]
we can now get smaller tighter but the
reactions of protections bigger okay so
for those that can do that the one you
do feel a release well when you feel the
second impulse you let that release go
to so now he basically hits the rock
hits my
right here with the thing level is
actually double zero otherwise the same
skill I released is ng pass through me
and then Jesus so rebound obviously
right and then but maybe you're not
believing it but if you pay attention
when you go you push and you are you see
that so anyways I got out here in my
week is sitting there waiting and it's
just one big
[Music]
I was okay the vector of his energies
actually irrelevant
okay so I know we should work and it
might be go on my skill because when she
touches me right she gonna trigger me
and I
or difference with that okay but it
should should be doable okay so cheese
cheese pushing well I don't want to
happen if she pushes but I don't wanna
do this either her energy
[Music]
okay
one two - okay so she's pushing right
you can see what she's doing - she's not
waiting on my shoulder but she's not
hanging out Go Go push me in the right
way okay she's doing this
so all my body oh good you see so she's
pushing and I have to send this he's
over the top lock that down
so here she's got me right and I have to
then I just kind of know her and she's
now going through me okay
maybe his Energy's going through me too
but I can't brace on him so she's
pushing this way to pay attention so I'm
gonna push back on Lily pushing and you
see that she was taking me that way
she's not pushing it she's got one
vector he's got another one okay so I'm
here and then you can see that I can
still move what you guys did is this
person is not pushing do that and then
you bracing Winky then you go in
okay and then we had lunch
so again you feel that leo okay maybe
two minutes you see it now they're just
so I'm just y'all so I would think this
is different this is going to be
different where she's not appreciate you
detection me but she's really she's
really pushing she's really trying to
knock you all right it's a lot of grace
there but she feels the price so now I
get rid of it and then I would say that
this you see what I'm waiting here
that's different so I'm just moving
[Music]
there's just certain things that I can
watch for in the key want to make sure
that I'm obeying those other principles
so the first principle is don't push on
the earth and keep their energy from
coming into their energy comes in and
press this on the earth the next thing
to look for is is my staff immediate or
is there the language would be
indicative that I was doing a bracing
angle okay then the third thing to look
for is really how much
is there in your movement because then
the other sectors can't go down to the
earth to the larger max you see that but
you you're stopping it at some angle or
at some point in your basic support okay
so it might look like they're doing the
technique you see but it does it's not
it doesn't look like a knife to me so I
can go slow relax
this is he can sense where he feels the
Dom Bianca laughs okay and I can play
with my timing so you know I can top but
so I'm gonna do this technique right and
here there seems to be a pause you see
but I could tell I wasn't so maybe
sometimes
legislation or sometimes I go ahead
[Music]
points right there if I relax in my pin
do the people like that okay all right
let's go you guys you abrasive beat
overpowers so you bring me then you
can't move so then you take the the
distal end lever concept here you see
that when you want your head in head go
ahead again you have to be able to to to
eject it doesn't matter how school you
go into this Center okay come on
well this time I'm ready to go here
Energy's coming in don't laugh I know no
crap oh crap I'm on the inside right it
won't move my how are you touch okay so
you can say he's coming in today
so his Energy's going both energies go
okay and then do the same xpadder
Tilton's body they send it over
thank you you're trying to do like just
because that's why I touch you see
[Music]
so don't try it if we're going to try to
trick the arts and we're not evolve you
know maybe we're trying to get the
perfect horrible we don't need it you
don't want it I can copy I'm going to
get it go let's go back well then I'm
not going to break his Energy's going
through me
do you feel that his Energy's going
through me it's not gonna go wrong with
me because that would be mouth let his
energy go around so his Energy's coming
in to me yeah your boy sending his
around you this is just like this was
supposed to be this drill is not
supposed to be this this draws his
energy spots an entity his energies
positive energies passing into and then
it through right and I am NOT ever going
to brace on him I just the energy and
the initial onslaught keep pops with me
[Applause]
[Music]
get ahold of my model
he's out there we see but it's the same
[Music]
okay it does matter where I'm touching
it it doesn't matter doesn't matter does
it matter
okay to stop looking for things fire
this
[Music]